I think I'm like shedding a little tear
right here today we're gonna be waxing
our nose hair from what I thought I
didn't have that much nose hairs but if
I ask a few people in the office I found
out I have some I don't think I have
hairy nostrils I think I'm very clean
should I look and see I've removed other
body hair but not nose hair but not nose
hair I'm nervous about ripping hairs out
of my nostrils but I'm excited to rip
the hairs out of my nostrils and not
have it in there there anymore
I'm scared that something's gonna happen
like an episode of Grey's Anatomy we're
like it's not actually a nose hair it's
like a nerve ending that's connected to
my brain and then I go into a
paraphyletic shop I am here for this and
I am about it I have a tremor
I've tried razor blades tried plucking
it and nothing works so this could be
like the thing then then I'll try it
well because I'm a five-year-old boy I
immediately laughed when I read the word
nads first off I love that it's called
Natalie just thank you I feel like dads
have knows there's like none my mind
went to gonads what's going on you balls
it's like if you took a small little
sucker stuck it in your nose and pulled
out your nose hairs that's this same
thing that I've noticed on here it says
it's painless I don't believe that at
all so you can do your nostrils the hair
on top of your nose and your unibrow
which is super cute cuz it's like three
in one this is the best part
facial hair protectors wait am I in
jeopardy of waxing off my facial hair by
accident all right say maybe you need to
wear one too I don't want to wipe off
but I have enough fat and you don't tell
me what I need the one that could appear
I don't want the biker gay mustache so
we're gonna start are you ready should
we taste it no so we have to heat up the
wax says for two minutes we throw this
full jar in there never allow the water
to boil overheated wax can cause serious
burns
we're in danger first things first I'm
putting this on
throughout do I need to sign a waiver
before I do this this is important to
time this with a watch for at least 90
seconds supposed to dip it in like that
and then pull it out like this turn it
like I'm making like a caramel dessert
yeah kind of sure I am NOT well and for
you for me
cheaters I think it's gonna make me pee
up myself
why are you gonna pee why is P even
involved in this give us a three count
one two work okay I'm gonna do it a good
consider me too yeah there's so much in
there good there we go yeah yeah they're
like a new fur coat I got you the other
one Oh oh my god
you gotta see what came out of your nose
I don't like now let's talk about it I
don't know if I want to talk about it I
learned that I have just as many hairs
in my nose as I thought I had and you
know they're all gone it's satisfying if
you like popping pimples or plugging
hairs it's great it's like painting a
wall you see results immediately I
learned actually the opposite I thought
I trimmed but to the contrary I would
totally do it again I would love to pull
Vonda out once a week if I can even
breathe better how often do I have to do
this I mean for you that's a week
minimum overall was a pleasant
experience didn't hurt that much was the
link took like three minutes tops and
got a lot of my little dudes out of my
nose thanks nads how come every time you
come
my nose hair nose we did not plan that
whatsoever
[Music]